monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
jour après jour
l'impact des prix de l'énergie sur les
usagers nos entreprises nos
collectivités territoriales d'en avoir
l'ampleur de la crise qui est devant
nous le mythe de la libéralisation du
secteur de l'énergie et de ces
mécanismes concurrentiels qui devait
faire baisser les prix non pas passer
l'épreuve de la réalité ils n'ont pas
protégé les consommateurs et les
consommatrices pas plus que les
économies européennes et je pense qu'il
faut être sur les faits plutôt que sur
les dogmes la proposition que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est de sortir du
marché européen l'énergie et de ce
mécanisme de construction des prix
de prendre un autre chemin que celle de
l'Europe du marché et des traders et de
construire ensemble une robe de
l'énergie qui réponde aux besoins
humains aux besoins vitaux à celle du
climat et qui protège les plus fragiles
des peuples européens et avant cela je
veux d'abord répondre à une
contre-vérité sortir du marché européen
serait sortir de l'interconnexion
européenne et le repli sur soi tout ceci
étant donné par un certain nombre de
membres du gouvernement
problème
le marché européen a été créé en 1997 et
les premières interconnexions celle qui
a vu la France l'Allemagne et la Suisse
crée des interconnexions c'est
1967 je propose donc que nous arrêtions
de répéter dans nos nez cette
contre-vérité et que nous les laissions
aux experts des plateaux de télévision
de BFM Business et que nous nous
concentrons sur les faits tout comme
nous pouvons faire du commerce sans
traiter de libre-échange climaticides
puisqu'on commerce depuis l'Antiquité
nous pouvons maintenir les
interconnexions et les échanges
solidaires plutôt que de laisser les
traders faire du profit car mes chers
collègues ce marché européen ne peut pas
fonctionner il repose sur des illusions
la première c'est que l'électricité est
une marchandise comme une autre et qu'on
pourrait donc organiser de toutes pièces
un marché ou une offre rencontrerez une
demande sauf que marcher s'organise
certes avec une offre et une demande
mais surtout avec un stock si l'offre
est supérieure à la demande le prix est
faible et inversement sauf que
précisément les dés sont pipés sur le
marché européen l'électricité puisque le
producteur doit produire ce que la
demande veut à l'instant T vous pouvez
donc vendre votre électricité à 1 € le
mégawater 10 100 ou 1000 la demande
devra l'acheter à ce prix là et de plus
les autorités régulatrices chez nous RTE
pourront toujours venir en secours au
dernier moment pour ajuster les besoins
s'il y a justement un risque cela ne
peut donc pas fonctionner d'autant plus
qu'avait le marché de gros et le marché
spot c'est un système qui favorise le
trading nous continuerons donc à dire
l'électricité est plus largement
l'énergie parce qu'elles sont
nécessaires et vitales à la vie doivent
être sortis du secteur marchand et
reconnu comme un bien de l'humanité
j'aimerais ensuite revenir sur une
deuxième illusion on a donc un marché
européen mais plusieurs stratégies
nationales de production nationale c'est
comme si nous avions un marché européen
de l'électricité mais que certains
construiraient des Ladas doivent des
Twingo d'autres des Ferrari et d'autres
des Mercedes et qu'ensuite on met tout
ça sur le même marché et qu'on leur
donne le même prix vous me diriez c'est
impensable mais oui mais précisément
c'est ce que nous faisons sur
l'électricité car quelle que soit le mix
électrique d'actionnal que vous soyez
aux énergies fossiles que vous auriez
sur les énergies renouvelables que vous
soyez sur l'hydraulique ou que vous
soyez sur le nucléaire on fixe le même
prix au niveau européen avec le coût
marginal c'est un fonctionnement qui
s'entend dans une stratégie nation mais
qui ne peut pas marcher sur un niveau
européen d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le
marché européen qui a créé le coût
marginal c'est Marcel Boiteux directeur
de cette grande entreprise qui fut EDF
de 1960 parce que peu importe que l'on
dépende peu du gaz comme nous moins
d'1%, ou pas par rapport aux Allemands à
40 %. nous payons le même prix et
contrairement à la promesse forte de
départ cela ne pousse pas les États
membres à décarboner leur stratégie de
production ou investir dans les énergies
renouvelables car quoi qu'il arrive et
même sans investissement vous paierez le
même prix que vos voisins ensuite la
troisième illusion le marché européen
mettra en lien des producteurs et des
acheteurs mais là où il y a un marché il
y a des traders c'est ce que nous avons
connu cet été avec un marché qui s'est
envolé avec un mégawattheure qui a
dépassé les 1000 euros ce n'est pas
sérieux et ce ne rend pas oser ni sur
les coûts de production ni même sur un
prix mais sur du trading et regarder
l'étendue des dégâts parce qu'il faut
donner des chiffres et des faits la
filiale Games qui est la filiale de
trading d'engie en 2021 écoutait bien
elle faisait 365 millions de bénéfices
combien en 2022 en pleine crise
énergétique deux milliards d'euros par
exemple Mint énergie qui a bénéficié de
la reine à
46,5 euros le méga wattheure la revendue
sur le même marché au prix de 257 euros
sans rien produire en quelques jours 6
millions d'euros nets et le pire
scandale c'est que l'État a financé mine
d'énergie pour appliquer le bouclier
tarifaire à hauteur de 12 millions
d'euros 1000 énergie qui ne produit rien
et qui raquette les usagers ces 18
millions de bénéfices net et il faut
donc arrêter ce massacre et se raquette
organisée oui il est possible de faire
autrement
avoir beaucoup de monde à droite et
partout sont maintenant comme nous pour
délayer le prix du gaz et de
l'électricité très bien mais comment
faire sans sortir de ce système vous
allez me dire on reste sur le coup
marginal sauf concernant le gaz mais on
va avoir un problème et c'est ce que
vous essayez de faire madame la ministre
c'est donc de plafonner et il y a trois
problèmes à ça cela un revient
subventionné une énergie fossile et
évidemment personne ici ne viendra dire
que c'est bon pour la planète le
deuxième problème c'est que les
Allemands bloquent évidemment puisqu'en
restant dans ce système qui lit le prix
du gaz et l'électricité ils ont un
avantage comparatif par rapport à nous
le troisième c'est que l'horizon 2023 et
2024 est très dégradé pour l'instant la
Chine est à l'arrêt mais lorsque ça va
repartir ils vont devoir acheter du gaz
à n'importe quel prix et donc
aujourd'hui nous avons du gaz américain
et katari mais 2023 et 2024 il y aura
une compétition internationale et donc
les prix vont flamber et donc ceux qui à
l'intérieur du marché européen ont tout
intérêt à continuer à lier le prix du
gaz et l'électricité continueront à
bloquer alors oui nous le disons nous
pouvons prendre un autre chemin et nous
pouvons agir dès maintenant et avoir une
vision à long terme dès maintenant c'est
obtenir une dérogation il faut arrêter
de nous dire que ce n'est pas possible
les Espagnols et les Portugais nous
l'ont montré non pas qu'il fallait
copier non pas que nous soyons dans la
même situation ils sont en bout de
chaîne nous sommes au cœur du réseau
mais ils ont montré que pour des États
membres il était possible d'avoir une
dérogation alors en boissons l'heure le
pas d'ailleurs l'Allemagne n'a pas
demandé de dérogation mais elle a mis
200 milliards sur la table pour
subventionner son économie
et nous demandons une dérogation pour
faire deux choses
réactiver les tarifs réglementés pour
tout le monde l'association
départementale de France des
départements de France le demande il
faut d'urgence
protéger les plus fragiles les usagers
les TPE et nos collectivités
territoriales et la blague qui vient à
dire que nous ayons obtenu des
énergéticiens un prix bloqué à 280 euros
est une aberration pourquoi parce que
les mêmes qui vous vendent dans 280
euros ont acheté pour 70% à 40 euros au
prix de la reine et donc écoutez bien
même sur ce les 30 derniers pour cent
même s'ils achètent sur le marché libre
à 800 euros ce qui serait une aberration
puisqu'il est entre 400 et 500 euros il
continueront à faire du profit donc il
faut un tarif réglementé bien sûr ça
coûte ces 3 milliards et demi mais l'an
dernier nous avons donné combien en
bouclier tarifaires ont la sécurité 43
milliards d'euros donc réactivons ce qui
marche dernière chose il faut en finir
avec la reine je n'ai pas assez de temps
mais vous comprendrez que c'est un
système qui dépouille ira raquettes EDF
et les usagers et enfin nous devons
prendre la tête en Europe sortir de ce
mécanisme européen des traders et de
l'énergie libérale et nous le pouvons
parce que nous sommes la France et un
péripété et dire que nous voulons garder
les interconnexions que nous voulons un
système qui protège l'ensemble des
consommateurs à des consommatrices et
qui se base surtout sur un mix
électrique national évidemment nous nous
devons faire valoir notre intérêt celui
du nucléaire mais nous devons aider
celles et ceux qui dépendent très
fortement des énergies fossiles non pas
par la compétition mais par la
coopération pour sortir
l'ensemble du système européen des
énergies fossiles et répondre aux
besoins vitaux des peuples qui auront
toujours besoin d'énergie voilà je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Musique]